j'entends la mer ça fait du bien
une vraie capsule 2d confiné et pourtant
elle n'est pas tous prêts à vol d'oiseau
au moins 200 km en fait nous entendons
leçons de notre corps plus précisément
celui du sang qui circule dans nos
vaisseaux le coquillage fait caisse de
résonance quand il est plaqué sur
l'oreille
il récupère le son qui se propage dans
le conduit auditif les ondes
rebondissent sur les parois solide du
coquillage et le son est amplifiée si on
reste immobile on entend un bruit de
fond mais si on bouge légèrement le
coquillage on obtient une variation qui
évoque le bruit des vagues dans le
lointain
entre nous ça marche aussi très bien
avec une boîte de maquereaux et même
avec un pot de confiture
je vous promets j'entends pas le champ
des fraises
enfin quand même avec celui ci sanaa
drôlement bien normal ces marais ou si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à la noyée sous les pouces bleus vous
pouvez également voir ou revoir celle
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le
côté gauche jean publie une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour éviter d'en
louper et bien abonnez vous et activer
la petite cloche à demain et n'oubliez
pas nous sommes toujours confiné mais en
restant lire